ja und wir schauen natürlich gemeinsam
noch mal auf den wahlverlauf auf den
auszählungsfehler und julian du hast
gerade als wir schon mal angesprochen
von den drei stufen wie sich das
abgespielt hat diese auszählung wenn du
das noch ein bisschen erläutern können
ja wir haben es eben gehört von den
amazon termin aus gehört red mirage die
rote erscheinung oder die rote vater
morgana
das phänomen dass die wahlkarte am
wahlabend immer roter und roter und
roter wurde und wir wollen uns jetzt
einmal anschauen wie hat sich diese rote
erscheinung innerhalb der letzten 48
stunden in trance blaues wunder für
trump oder in schramms blauen albtraum
kann man sagen er verwandelt und
tatsächlich handelt es sich dabei um ein
modell was sozusagen in zeigt das einmal
hier vor unserem ipad in drei stufen
funktioniert das heißen diese drei
stufen das gucken wir uns auch einmal
gleich an stufe 1 ist sozusagen die
mauer gegen einstellen
trump sieg und das hier stufe 1 ist die
mauer können wir uns einmal hier
angucken wenn wir jetzt nach arizona
gucken
die mauer ist sozusagen die normale
mobilisierung im wahlkampf das ist alles
das was hier so hellblau angezeigt ist
besonders hier das ist erst mal geld
erst mal verhindern dass ein staat zu
schnell an den konkurrenten in diesem
fall donald rumsfeld stufe 2 auf dem
zwei auf dem drei stufen bleibt die
stufe 3 stufe 2 ist sozusagen die joe
biden rakete die joe biden rakete in
stufe 2 hielt die tür die tor beiden
rakete ab wie kommt es zu dieser joe
biden rakete nicht nur joe biden und die
joe biden rakete sieht man hier in
dieser enormen mobilisierung 73,9 25
millionen stimmt was 74 millionen
stimmen die joe biden rakete woher kommt
die tour beiden rakete wer hat sie zum
abheben gebracht nicht nur die beiden
wenn wir uns den wahlkampf von joe biden
an
geguckt haben dann würde man als letztes
sind vergleich einer rakete mit dem ziel
diese beiden raketen oder zumindest das
was hier unten an treibstoff drin ist
und was diese enorme mobilisierung
herbeigeführt hat das war zu großen
teilen auch donald trump donald trump
hat im demokratischen lager oder auch im
lager von vielleicht nicht so
politisiert politisiert menschen jungen
menschen eine solche abstoß reaktion
hervorgerufen dass sich das übersetzt
hat in diese enorme wahlbeteiligung in
diese enormen zahlen und dann diese 74,9
und dann stufe 3 und das ist das was wir
sehen derzeit im moment besonders in den
großstädten hier sehen wir zum beispiel
in phoenix und den tucson
wenn wir uns hier die wahlergebnisse war
ergebnisse angucken hier sieht man 50
prozent agio beiden hier unten sieht man
60 prozent für joe biden
das sind leute merken und 55 bis 60
prozent dass es diese stufe zwei dieser
enorme zur beiden rakete und dann kommt
das was wir jetzt in den letzten stunden
erlebt haben die stufe drei und stufe 3
ist die briefwahl
die briefwahl ist das was jetzt gerade
das ergebnis zum kippen bringt und was
das ergebnis ganz dramatisch noch einmal
in richtung von joe biden aussetzen wenn
wir uns jetzt hier noch einmal anschauen
beiden gegen trump in pima county hier
unten mit der stadt tucson in arizona
da haben wir bisher 70 prozent für joe
biden
dieses ergebnis geht derzeit weiter hoch
warum das hat etwas mit stufe 3 zu tun
und stufe 3 ist die briefwahl und in
stufe drei villen derzeit bis zu 80 80
in philadelphia wir bis zu 90 prozent
stimmen für joe biden und all das führt
aller höchstwahrscheinlich dann in
diesem drei stufen modell hier oben zu
der entscheidenden zahl 270 und das ist
dann das weiße haus wie gesagt bisher
sind wir noch nicht da aber vermutlich
dauert das nicht mehr lange
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren